what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of really
exciting Marvel Studios news to talk
about specifically in regards to the
King Dynasty and Ken specifically in
regards to how bad King is actually
going to be now of course we know he is
the big bad of the Multiverse Saga and
we just got an official debut of a Kang
in Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania but
what is in store for his future well it
sounds like he is going to be bigger and
badder than he was in Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania which I know a lot of
people are going to be really excited to
hear now Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania was written by Jeff loveness
and Jeff loveness is also going to be
writing Kang Dynasty and he's recently
shared a little bit of what to expect
from Kang in the next Avengers film we
also have some news about some new
Avengers members yes even more news and
Tina cuerta returning to reprise his
role as nemour as they call him in Black
Panther wakanda forever but let's go
ahead and start off with a little
preview of what to expect from Kang in
the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
according to writer Jeff loveness he is
going to be killing some of our Avengers
now many people thought that Ant-Man
would die and Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and although we did have
that one scene where we kind of saw some
different versions of Ant-Man die no
spoilers there that scene is in the
trailers however the true main Ant-Man
didn't die he made it out of the movie
all right but it looks like in the
upcoming movies Kang is going to live up
to the title big bad and apparently the
reason that Ant-Man survived Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania is because they
want to differentiate Kang from Thanos
they didn't want Kang to come in and
start killing people right away like
Thanos did in Avengers Infinity War
while speaking with comicbook.com writer
for Ant-Man and the wasp's Quantum Mania
and the King Dynasty Jeff leviness
talked about and addressed some
characters possibly meeting their and he
said I think for these bloodthirsty fans
there's a little movie called Avengers
Kang Dynasty I think he'll bring the
heat now comicbook.com asked him if
there were some seismic deaths on the
table when writing Ant-Man and the WASP
of quantumania and here's how we address
this he says they were we certainly
gamed out a ton of scenarios but it just
felt a little obvious it's Up For Debate
but it just felt like we'd be copying
the Thanos approach where he comes in
pretty heavy and wipes the floor with
everybody I certainly see the critiques
and all that but this is a multi-step
story that we're telling it's also an
Ant-Man movie so keep in mind that
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania was
really designed as an introduction to
Kang this is something that gives me a
lot of comfort because I really did want
Kang to be bigger but we had to keep in
mind that this was still at the heart of
it in Ant-Man movie however in the movie
they did make it pretty obvious that
Kang has killed a lot of Avengers before
in fact he's killed so many of that
they've all kind of started to blur
together to him he said but he does say
that writing quantumania in the Kang
Dynasty is kind of like putting a bunch
of different puzzle pieces together he
continues to talk and says I mean
certainly in these Marvel rooms and all
that you certainly game out all these
stories and you pitch them out you write
them out and you're trying to land the
best puzzle piece because there's so
many characters in The Ensemble and due
to the fact that there are so many
characters it seems like some of them
are indeed going to die in fact he makes
that pretty obvious while speaking about
why Ant-Man himself didn't die in
quantumania he says I think people say
they want that but do you really want to
see Paul Rudd get murdered in his third
movie it was all debated all discussed
and all gamed out but in The Wizard of
Oz you don't want to see Dorothy die and
never go home it's supposed to be one of
these classic adventure movies if
everyone gets eaten in Jurassic Park I
don't know if you'll want to see the
next Jurassic Park however when talking
about deaths he ends by saying this but
I wouldn't worry too much about Kang's
kill count he's going going to rack up
some kills as he goes along now since
Jeff loveness has just said this and he
is writing the Kang Dynasty this means
that some Avengers are indeed going to
die in the King Dynasty and also keep in
mind that we are definitely going to be
seeing King before the King Dynasty
they're supposed to be multiple variants
of him showing up in Loki season 2. we
just heard that there are going to be a
few variants showing up in shangchi 2 as
well and who knows where else and when
else Kang is going to pop up before the
Kang Dynasty so we could be seeing some
deaths in the MCU relatively soon now I
know some fans like this and some fans
don't but one thing that Kang killing
some Avengers does is make it to where
he is viewed as a very big threat and
here's one thing that I actually hope
they do differently with Kang than they
did with Thanos I hope Kang physically
kills some people yes Thanos killed half
of the Avengers team by snapping but we
didn't physically see him kill anybody
he didn't kill anybody on Titan when
fighting the Avengers team or really
anywhere else yes we did see how brutal
he was and that he could take on
everybody but he didn't physically kill
anybody himself and that is because in
thanos's heart he actually thought that
he was saving the universe Kang on the
other hand is very different he wants to
conquer the Multiverse not just one
universe but every Universe out there
and he will do so by killing everyone
and I really want them to show that I
want them to show how ruthless King is
so the fact that some Avengers are going
to die is sad but I think is very
necessary if you want to show how big
and how bad can the Conqueror actually
is now who is going to die in Avengers
the King Dynasty right now we really
have no idea anybody is really up for
grabs obviously we know that there are
characters like the Scarlet Witch who is
going to have projects for herself after
Secret Wars she's not going to die
clearly the same thing goes with
Spider-Man if the deal that we heard
about him recently is true then he is
definitely having movies after the King
Dynasty in fact his next Spider-Man
movie is supposed to take place after
the King Dynasty so he is safe but
others could be in trouble also they
could show Kang killing characters in
other universes not necessarily ours
which some fans might enjoy more that
way the characters all get to go to
Secret Wars and fight Kang as a giant
multiversal team but from there I am
expecting characters to die much like an
Avengers end game we lost Tony Stark and
Natasha Romanov and speaking of
characters coming together Jeff lobnes
has also talked about with comicbook.com
that he is writing for Namor in Avengers
the King Dynasty confirming that Namor
is going to be in the film now this is
really exciting because a lot of people
really loved nemour and wakanda forever
including myself and this makes sense
because if there is a huge World threat
and a multiversal threat then you're
gonna need all of the power that you can
possibly get and we know wakanda is
going to be involved and at the end of
wakan forever shuri and Namor kind of
made a deal to help each other and like
no more said it would be in his interest
to help wakanda that way when wakanda
needs help and they help wakanda will
eventually return the favor to them
which is what nemour actually wants no
more wants to rule the world but you
know it's kind of hard to rule a world
if it's being ruled by somebody else
Kang the Conqueror but in the comics the
more is kind of a good guy he's more of
an anti-hero sometimes he fights with
the Avengers sometimes against them but
it looks like he is going to be joining
them to fight Kang in the Kang Dynasty
or who knows maybe he'll actually join
Kang we'll have to wait and see on that
one and speaking of New Avengers like I
mentioned in the beginning of the video
it looks like we have some new members
of The New Avengers team revealed to us
Grace Randolph has recently said that
Destin Daniel who is going to be
directing the King Dynasty wants the
Hulk She-Hulk and Moon Knight to be a
part of the Avengers lineup in Kang
Dynasty and Kevin feige wants Daredevil
to be a part of that lineup as well this
comes as little to no surprise as these
are basically the characters that
appeared in phase 4. and Kevin feige
obviously told us that the Disney Plus
shows are going to connect to the bigger
movies so these characters are going to
be joining Sam Wilson's Captain America
they'll be joining Spider-Man and most
likely Captain Marvel as well will any
of these Heroes die though since Kang
Dynasty is going to bring deaths I'm
guessing no since these are going to be
some of the main Avengers but we never
know we'll have to wait to find out but
in the meantime let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below who
do you think is going to die be sure to
let us know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the latest MCU news for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof